Test good afternoon. Everyone. Can you guys hear me? Okay? Hello everyone. My name is Elaine. How are you guys?
They can hear me. Okay. Okay, we're gonna get started in a couple minutes. We've had to pivot a little bit today
So I appreciate everybody's patience
We we really appreciate you guys hanging around because we put a lot of time and energy into this product pitch
We're gonna start about I'm gonna say about 10 minutes, but we've got a really cool
Cool. Turn it up. Can you crank it up? We want to thank DJ Alpha out of London. He put together a
really cool remix for Canada. We're going to play it as soon as we're done. We're going to have our
contestants and our participants up here along with our judges. We're also going to record this
so anybody who doesn't have access to see us or fully hear us, don't worry. You will get a copy
of this emailed out to you so hold tight everyone you guys are also welcome to
come on to the stairs if you'd like to see it if you're stuck under there by
all means utilize every space we've got I have a prime minister I speak English
English and French, not American.
But we are crisis.
For sure, Canada, oh, oh, oh, Canada.
Oh, Canada, oh, oh, oh, Canada.
Now she want a photo.
You already know that.
You only live once.
That's the motto to Kiolo.
And we about it every day, every day, every day.
Like we sitting on a bench, but we don't really play.
Every day, every day, let anybody stay.
Can't see them, because I'm money in the way, real .
I can't put my face when I'm with you.
I know I can treat you better than he can.
You and me, never see us fall apart
Kind of love, I swear it's made for both of us
And I fall asleep, up next to you
Touch the bottom, and be free
Caught you red-eyed, and I am
And prints on your rover, you smell like Corona
Get full-on, they don't take them over
You tell me that you don't own
So what's this?
We'll be right back.
He went to the washroom, he's down at the bottom of the stairs.
Oh he's coming.
Okay.
on Brandon. Everybody say hi to Brandon. Jacob be nice. I saw that.
Were we supposed to? No.
Megan and I are going to groom ourselves on the same page.
Okay, welcome everyone. Thank you guys once again all for being here. Before we start,
Can we get a round of applause, not only for our team, but for you guys, for really coming together and making this event happen.
Awesome.
Well, like I said, hello, everyone.
My name is Elaine Pritchett.
I am the director of sales and marketing here.
I have the coolest job.
Take a look around.
It's been a blast.
Pop mic.
I didn't do it.
And he just got recruited into this job, actually.
That's not a lie.
He's taking over next year.
So I think that's quite good.
A couple reminders.
Raffle tickets.
If you guys have any tickets, I want you to come up here to the front and put them in the owner's or the employee's bid.
And he will be drawing this directly after the product pitch.
Okay?
One other thing, anybody who's got a product pickup order, you've got little tags for them today.
They are available around the side of the building.
Once you guys are ready to go, you're welcome to go over there and pick up your product.
There will be a little bit of a lineup later on, so if you get a chance to go over there before that, that would be excellent.
Today we've kind of done something a little bit different.
We have something very, very special for you.
We reached out to all of you, we asked you if you would like to pitch a product to us.
How many people have been standing in their salon and thought,
Oh my god, this is an amazing product.
Why isn't this ingredient in this product?
Why haven't we thought about this?
Why is there more product with coconut in it?
You guys definitely disagree?
Big heads.
Well, you know what?
We got a lot of applications.
And a lot of them came in from across the country.
We received some from Newfoundland, from British Columbia, and quite a few from Ontario.
So I want to give everybody a round of applause for A, submitting an application.
And a second round of applause for our five participants.
This is very intimidating for them.
So we do have some judges up here as well.
Our judges are going to be rating these products.
You will see a rating from 1 to 100 on their whiteboard.
So at the end of the product pitch, they will be rating them.
We do have a QR code that you're able to scan as well.
So we want you guys to judge these products as well.
There is a QR code.
I'm assuming it's on that TV down there.
Okay.
Okay, good.
So at the end of the presentation, there will be a QR code.
You guys will scan it with your phones, and you'll be able to judge the products as well.
Okay?
So you're definitely involved.
The louder you are, the more excited you are about products.
It resonates, right?
So we will definitely have a winner today.
We've got three amazing prizes of anywhere from $200 to $500, guys.
So we're paying these people for their hard work as well.
Okay, so like I said, we've got five expert judges.
These judges combined have over 100 years of experience.
And that's just me.
Yeah.
Our first judge actually joins us from St. Louis, Missouri, welcome Gina, welcome Jack,
Jack is right across the border in Michigan, she's our neighbor, she's our dear friend,
they're all our friends but she's the closest.
our next two guests left the florida heat brought it with them right we've got brandon from enove
formerly known as funless ink
and michaela from devoted street
you guys had the the you guys were able to play some games and meet all of our other vendors as
well like i said before we are very lucky to have them with us and their support means a lot
appreciate that um so i'm going to pass the mic over to leanne and she's going to introduce her
first product hey guys uh my name is leanne tyson i have been uh literally part of the
furniture and you've relaxed for almost 20 years now so I am so so excited to be up here with Elaine
as part of this product pitch presentation. I know I can see there's quite a few of you that
are still back here maybe want to have a better view. We can fill in this area a little bit more
and you're more than welcome to fill up the stairs a bit if you want a better view okay. I want
everybody to have a chance to see what's going on if they can. For those of you who don't see
everything or feel that you don't have the best view we are recording this presentation so this
presentation will then be emailed out to those of you in attendance so you can watch it again okay
all right so without further ado i'm going to bring up our first presenter miss sherry hawk
Sherry Hawk is from Sun HQ in Curtis, Ontario and Sherry can you please tell us about your
product.
Pretend you're stuck on an elevator with me for two minutes and give me your best pitch.
okay here we go oh no you're not no you're not on
we're ready okay the name of our product is called glow burst it's not just about color
it's about radiant healthy skin glow burst is a bronzer with a pop of hydration moisture reads
seeds pop as you immerse your skin with hydration. An airless pump allows for easy dispensing
and a peachy silicone-encased bottle makes the product pop on your shelf. Notes of pineapple
and mango refresh the senses and bring uplifting freshness, ending with a sun-kissed glowy
Now for those of you concerned that you haven't seen the product, you will see it at the end
when you use...
Oh, I just saw the screen down there.
Oh, perfect.
All right.
You guys are ahead of me.
I thought you were going to have to make the QR code.
You have a visual.
That's excellent.
All right.
So I'm going to pass this over to our judges.
Who's got the first question?
Michaela.
Yeah.
Perfect.
So the beads in there, you said they're moisture beads, right?
Correct.
What do they offer that...
any other ingredients like a moisturizing ingredient? What do they offer beyond those?
It gives an added texture to the product so if you think back to I believe back in the old days
there's a lotion called ganja and when you pumped it, it would crack kind of coming through so it
kind of gives that added experience or sensory experience when it's coming through. Be filled
with hyaluronic acid or vitamin E to just give that pop with a sensory portion of kind of adding it to your skin.
Question about the formula, like the feel. Is it more like a silicone base? Is it able to be like one of those hybrid products where you can, you know, use it in a UV bed and then spray with it as well?
Nope. We're going to stay clear of that. DHA bronzer in it and silicone free.
Perfect. And then I have one last question and that's about the airless pump.
Yes. So I know a lot of people do get confused about airless pumps just because sometimes, you know, air can kind of get sucked in there.
And then, you know, it takes a second to pump it down and you have to turn it over, smack it or any of those crazy things.
Is there any other, you know, like tube or component you guys had ever considered beyond the airless pump, just in case?
No, we really like the airless pump because then you know you're getting 100% of your product out.
Ambrosia was a huge product with an airless pump, went through different...